[Music]
my name is George I'm the CEO at five
Tran five Tran is a data pipeline a
automated data pipeline that syncs data
from all of these places and many more
this slide is actually now quite out of
date into your data warehouse and last
summer we did this benchmark as was just
mentioned benchmarks depend a lot on how
you do them we thought that there we
looked and looked and found that there
was not a good benchmark in my opinion
out there comparing data warehouses and
in particular we wanted to do a
benchmark that described the kind of
scenario that our customers actually
faced so our customers are typically
syncing data from lots of places they
have complicated schemas we deliver
normalized schemas so they have complex
queries and generally the data sets are
not huge it's not the size of the data
that's the primary problem it's the
complexity of it so we compared these
three data warehouses which are the main
data warehouses that we support as
destinations before I get into the
details of the benchmark I just want to
take a moment to explain the difference
between OLTP and OLAP data sources I am
sorry if this is old news to you but I'm
always amazed by how many very technical
people don't realize this distinction
and just how different these are so
every chance I get I explain this again
just trying to put it out into the world
how different data warehouses are from
transactional databases so in the world
of sequel databases there's really two
kinds of sequel databases there's sequel
databases that are designed for online
transaction processing that's where you
do something like go get one row out of
my database you know here's the primary
key go get me this one row and you might
grab all the columns but it's a very
shallow query you're just grabbing one
or a few rows the other kind of database
is designed to support
analytical processing that's where you
say scan through all of my data probably
only look at a couple of columns so just
grab you know the email of the author if
in this scenario we're imagining that
we're querying a table of github commits
just grab the author's email and just
count up how many commits they did so
it's the opposite query pattern right
we're wearing few columns but we're
scanning the entire data set every time
and this talk is about that that second
scenario even though they both use
sequel the data stores that are designed
for that second kind of query are
organized in a different in fact the
opposite way so classic databases like
Postgres and my sequel are row stores we
often visualize data you know in this
table format but you can't actually
store data that way right you have to
store data linearly and the fundamental
strategy that most transactional
databases use is their their row stores
so you go from left to right and then
from top to bottom right you store the
value of commit and then the value of
file and the value of added and what
that means is that one row will all the
all the elements from one row will be
sitting next to each other like you see
here column stores are in fact done in
the opposite way so they store an entire
column sequentially so we store all of
the commit values and then we store all
of the file names and then we store all
of the added counts and and these column
store data warehouses are designed to
support that that second query pattern
so the most obvious way in which this is
better if you're doing that second query
pattern is that if you are only
interested in the file column and the
change column you can skip reading most
of the data right you can just read one
of each of those columns so all three
data warehouses that we're benchmarking
here are of the second kind column store
and the the benchmark we're doing is
designed to test that kind of query
pattern the first just a little bit of
history of when these data warehouses
came out the first
true columnstore data warehouse that
really put it all together was C store
which was way back in 2005 C store later
became Vertica it was an academic
project it's not just a matter of having
a columnar disk format to make a good
column store data warehouse you need to
have a different kind of execution
engine really every layer of it is stiff
is designed differently except the top
layer the sequel so C store came out in
2005 the first data warehouse of the
ones that were gonna benchmark here
today to come out was actually bigquery
but there really are two big queries the
bigquery that became available in 2011
was very different than the bigquery we
have today it was not very good at doing
joins I could only do broadcast joins
Google decided to make their own dialect
of sequel for some reason so it had a
non-standard language which kind of
looked like sequel but it wasn't the
same and not a lot of people used it you
so you couldn't do complex queries that
did like fact effect joins you had to
adapt to this weird pseudo sequel
language there were no updates there
were a lot of things that were missing
it was not really very usable for
anybody outside of Google at that time
the into the big thing that happened in
our space was redshift coming out in
2013
redshift was not the first good columnar
data warehouse but it was the first good
columnar data warehouse that was cheap
so you could go into the AWS console and
for not that much money you could have a
really fast columnar data warehouse
redshift has kind of a funny Providence
it came from par Excel Amazon actually
bought the source code from another
company which is kind of a weird thing
to do you don't often see that happening
but they bought the source of our excel
and turned it into redshift that has as
well seal it see you later
I think proven to be somewhat of a
problem for them in recent years they've
had trouble evolving it and keeping up
with some of the other data warehouses
in the last couple years it's been it's
it got them to market quickly but it's
that later proven hard for them to
change
snowflake came out in 2015
snowflake is similar to bigquery in that
it stores the data separately from where
it does the compute so they store the
actual data of your tables in s3 and
then they can provision any number of
compute nodes that they want to to read
that data other than that it's basically
fundamentally similar to redshift and
other columnar data warehouses but it
had this marquee feature which was the
separation of compute from storage and
they they came out into 2015 they really
started to take off in like early 2017
bigquery was not to be counted out
though in 2016
bigquery started getting a lot better
Google released a new dialect of sequel
that followed the standard they improved
their query planners so you could
actually do fact effect joins they
implemented DML and they've continued so
bigquery in the last couple years has
gotten a lot better and it's become much
more usable for regular analysts who
don't work at Google so those are the
three major data warehouses we support
and the ones that we tested in this
benchmark so what the heck did we query
here we queried a data set from the tpc
EDS benchmark which is a standard
benchmark used for data warehouses it's
a pretty conventional dimensional schema
this is actually only part of it there's
more fact tables and more dimension
tables it's a pretty complicated schema
and we're gonna run some pretty
complicated queries which is important
but it looks like a pretty normal
dimensional data warehouse schema we ran
it at a 100 gigabyte scale which is
pretty low usually people do much larger
scales especially vendors they like to
say that we can you know handle all of
these terabytes and terabytes of data
but what we find is that most of our
customers who are loading data from
relational databases from Salesforce
from support systems their data sets are
not that large but they don't want to
allocate a giant data warehouse and
want to get sub second or sub 10 seconds
type queries so it's not about you know
can you crunch through a petabyte of
data in half an hour it's about can you
crunch through 100 gigabytes of data in
5 seconds that's what we're really
testing here the queries we ran are the
TPC DS queries so these are pretty
complex queries the one on the left is a
pretty simple one you still are joining
a bunch of dimension tables onto a fact
table there the fact table is web sales
and item and date dam or dimension
tables they contain complicated
predicates they contain aggregations
many of them contain multiple sub
queries that later get joined together
they sometimes have fact to fact joins
so these are these are complicated
queries with complicated query plans
which is an important part of this
benchmark because this is the kind of
query that we see in the wild when real
customers query their real data sets
they're not just like you know nice the
one giant wide table there's lots of
joins and crazy stuff going on there so
our view is that it's really important
to do these kinds of complicated queries
and that's why we chose the DB CD s
benchmark just in case you're wondering
who is this DBS TPC TPC is the
transaction processing council so
they're like a group of vendors and
academics who created this and several
other benchmarks they have this lovely
website which looks like it came from a
time warp from 1998 but it's it's a good
benchmark and it is a standard that a
lot of try and people will follow now
just running the DB CD s benchmark isn't
specific enough so it's very common for
vendors to run T PCBs on their own data
warehouses and it's very common for them
to cheat as I put it you will not be
surprised to find that whenever a vendor
runs this benchmark their data warehouse
is always the best one and there are
lots of little choices you make
you run these things that matter a lot
for the result you're gonna get and we
made this these choices in a very
careful way that was designed to test
what we think are the important
characteristics of data warehouses but I
want to talk a little bit about why we
made these choices and you can make your
own opinion of whether we did this in
the right way sometimes people agree and
sometimes people get very mad at me and
they think you know you did this the
wrong way but at least I'll just tell
you exactly what it is and we did it
fairly across all of them so the first
thing you need to do is you need to not
run the same query twice in a row if
you're on the exact same query twice in
a row well a big query for example will
just give you the cached result from the
previous run and the other data
warehouses aren't quite as aggressive
about caching well snowflake will do
that too but they also have the ability
to cache intermediate values of queries
some data warehouses have this and it's
just not a very realistic scenario
that's not what we want to test whether
you can just cash previous results and
give them back to us so you need to be
sure that you set up your data warehouse
you warm it up but that you don't give
the data warehouse the exact same query
twice in a row the second choice we made
is we did not use disk keys so disk keys
are an optimization that you can apply
to data warehouses data warehouses are
multi node systems and if you want to
you can designate one column and say
distribute the data according to this
column and when you do this it will make
some joins really fast so for example if
I wanted to run this query where I join
web sales to item and I know I'm going
to join on the item key I can tell the
data warehouse in advance distribute the
data according to the item key and then
what it's going to do is let's say it
has two nodes and there's two item keys
it'll put all of the data for item one a
node one and I'll put all the data for
node for item two on node two and then
when I do this this eques join on the
item key the data warehouse knows that
the data is already distributed
according to this item key and so it'll
skip the shuffle step if you don't do
this
then the first step of every join is you
have to shuffle the data between nodes
on whatever the equi-join key is before
you can do anything else you skip that
huge step these joins will go way faster
if you do this this is a good
optimization that you should do if you
can the problem is you can't always do
this
this only sometimes works you can't
distribute on every key and our view is
that the important performance measure
is how fast you are when this doesn't
work when this trick is not available
how fast can you go that's the thing
that's really going to differentiate one
data warehouse from another so we chose
not to use disk keys at all the the
second somewhat controversial choice
that we made is we did not use sort or
partition keys so this is another
optimization you can do where if you
know in advance what your queries are
going to look like you can give the data
warehouse this hint so you what you can
do is say if you have like a date column
in your table you can tell the data
warehouse to sort the the data on that
date in redshift it's called the sort
key snowflake and bigquery have a
slightly different but similar strategy
where you don't exactly sort each file
on that key but you partition the data
on that key and then if you run a query
that has a where Clause like this where
you say where the date is in some range
the query planner will just jump to the
appropriate place in this file you can't
really see it but I've highlighted in
yellow this part right here so what will
happen is if it knows in advance that
the data is laid out on this order it
can just skip all the data up to the
point where the predicate applies and
there are two reasons why we opted not
to apply this optimization to any of
these data warehouses the first is the
same reason from before the the date
partitioning trick is not always
available and it's really important to
measure the performance of the data
warehouse when the tricks don't work
the the second reason is that the TPC DS
benchmark contains a lot of tape
predicates in it and if you use this
trick the benchmark ends up just being
about how well you can do how well you
can do date partitioning it in the TP
CBS in particular many many of the
queries have these predicates on the
dates and so it ends up kind of
dominating the benchmark so we opted not
to use sort or partition keys we did
apply compression we did the the basic
optimizations that are very Universal
and robust that that will just make
queries faster in general so we did all
the basic optimizations of the data like
compression but we didn't do any of
these sort of tricks that make a huge
difference but only apply sometimes so
the first way we evaluated the results
is we looked at the execution time 499
TPC des queries we used a pretty small
warehouse so the snowflake and redshift
warehouses we used or both configured to
cost two dollars an hour which is a
pretty small data warehouse but again
what we see a lot in the wild as people
who have datasets that are not that huge
but they're looking for really fast
response times and for bigquery there is
no such thing as a bigquery size
bigquery is just a pure web service it's
like Gmail you just send your query off
and the results come back and it ran
somewhere so when you run bigquery
you're just running on bigquery there is
no such thing as a node size that's
going to be tricky when we compare
pricing in a second but for time we just
measured the the raw time and we found
that they're all similar you know
bigquery was the fastest by a little bit
but these are not big differences you
should not choose the data warehouse
because in one benchmark one finished in
eight seconds and another finished in
six seconds
and the fact that they are so similar is
a good sign
if we saw dramatically different results
from different similarly configured data
warehouses that would be extremely
surprising the basic techniques to make
a fast columnar data warehouse have been
known for more than ten years now it
would be very weird if snowflake was way
way way faster than redshift so the fact
that we got similar times is a good sign
that indicates we probably did the
benchmark right
the second way we compare them and this
is the more interesting one is we
compare them based on cost so comparing
snowflake and redshift on cost is simple
you just multiply the execution time by
$1 per hour number but comparing to
bigquery is tricky because bigquery has
this fundamentally different pricing
model big gray doesn't charge you per
hour that your warehouse is running they
discharge you per query but this is a
really important factor to consider and
so to address this question we actually
looked at data from our 300 customers on
how they actually ran their data
warehouses we looked across five trans
customer base at what percentage of time
their data warehouse is actually running
a query because that's what you need to
know in order to make an
apples-to-apples comparison between say
running redshift which charges you by
the hour that the warehouse is running
and running bigquery which just charges
you per query so if you're running
redshift you're not going to have
perfect back-to-back-to-back-to-back
queries using it all the time some of
that time that you're paying for
redshift is just going to be wasted and
if so if you know the percentage of time
that your warehouse is actually running
something you can calculate an actual
per query cost for redshift and it turns
out that across our customer base the
average percentage of time that the
warehouses are actually doing something
is about 20% which may surprise some
people in this audience that it is solo
everyone imagines their data warehouse
is you know this incredibly important
resource is very expensive
you must be running things on it all the
time but the reality is the way most of
our customers use their data warehouse
is to power dashboards in bi tools and
that means there's a lot of times of day
when nobody is clicking on anything on
the dashboards unless you have many
thousands of users using these
dashboards most of the day most seconds
there's not going to be anyone
requesting a query especially if you
have these data warehouses configured to
be big enough to give you like five
second response times if you if you're
having five second response times unless
you have thousands of BI users you are
not going to be running anything on your
warehouse most of the day so using that
factor that 20% factor we were able to
convert the snowflake and redshift
numbers from a price per hour to a price
per query and make an apples-to-apples
comparison to bigquery and on that basis
bigquery ends up being about twice as
expensive as the other warehouses which
wasn't surprised to us we kind of
figured they had probably calibrated
their pricing model to be you know just
exactly equivalent to their competitors
but this this does square with what
we've heard from users who have used
both systems the bigquery is a little
bit more expensive at the end of the day
you're gonna spend more money on your
own staff and on all the tools around
your data warehouse so this isn't this
isn't a reason that no one should ever
use bigquery but you should just know
that it is a little bit more expensive
the other thing you need to keep in mind
when interpreting this plot is that it
is entirely dependent on that percentage
of use factor right so if you have a
situation where you use your data
warehouse 80% of the time for whatever
reason you just have jobs queued up all
the time and it's always busy then big
gray is gonna be a really bad deal
comparatively for you on the other hand
if you use your data warehouse very
rarely if you have a very spiky workload
so that it's only active like 5% of the
time as some people do then bigquery is
gonna be a great deal it's gonna be way
cheaper because of its different pricing
level so you should interpret this
carefully you you want to adjust that
based on your own scenario
of how active your data warehouse is
we're not the only people ever to run
benchmarks comparing these data
warehouses and I just wanted to talk
quickly about how our benchmark compares
to others
the first one is Amazon did a benchmark
comparing redshift to bigquery
unsurprisingly they found that redshift
was much better as lenders always do
when they compare their their products
to others they ran TP CH not TP CD s TP
CD S is a better benchmark for comparing
warehouses so that was a little bit of a
not great choice they also ran an
extremely large redshift this is a very
big expensive redshift cluster that they
ran in order to get these really short
times so you have to take that with the
grain of salt
it's not clear that this is really an
apples to apples comparison they also um
they ran a really large data set and I'm
guessing they probably didn't call up
Google and ask for a greater slots quota
which is what you would do if you have
massive data sets that you want to run
through bigquery there's quotas on big
crayon how much computer will allocate
to you unless you call up and ask them
and I'm guessing they probably didn't
ask for a larger quota when they ran
this benchmark they didn't publish any
of those details so we don't know they
didn't like publish the code they used
to produce the benchmark so we can't
reproduce it but that is my suspicion a
periscope who's also here at the
conference also ran a redshift vs.
snowflake versus bigquery benchmark they
did it a little bit earlier than ours
and I think snowflake was less fast at
that time so snowflake came out a little
bit worse this is a a a
cost-effectiveness plot so I think
snowflake at that time was a little bit
slower than it was when we did this
benchmark last summer and the other
thing they did is they also attempted to
compare cost and they had similar
numbers of you
they looked at their own customers and
they found it was significantly less
than 50% usage time for for for what
percentage of time the data warehouse
was actually running anything
the last difference between periscopes
benchmark and ours is that where we did
TP CVS they did a much simpler benchmark
where they just had two tables and they
did one join between them so their
benchmark is more of a measure of just
the flat-out scan speed of the warehouse
as opposed to your ability to run
complex queries and it probably is the
case that redshift is faster at those
flat-out scans if snowflake is loading
the data out of s3 it's a little bit
complicated because snowflake once you
query a table repeatedly it'll actually
cache the data locally and then it's not
reading out of s3 anymore but if you if
you measure from a cold start redshift
should be faster at just doing like a
flat-out scan out of s3 so those are the
differences that account for why their
benchmark is different than ours I think
ours is a better measure if what your
goal is is to run complex queries are
running T BCD s is more relevant than
the simpler query they ran here but it's
good to know that they're in the same
universe and they had similar numbers on
that percentage of use time of data
warehouses as we did which is a really
important factor in comparing big grade
to the other data warehouses the last
one is this taxi benchmark which some
people may have heard of which has a
very comprehensive set of data
warehouses the the taxi benchmark uses
very different sized data warehouses
that it compares across ov so it's
pretty apples and oranges and they it's
a very simple query they're just
querying one big table so this really is
just a measure of scan speed i I don't
think this is very useful for predicting
how your data warehouse will actually
perform it's kind of it's almost
all GPU databases that win this
particular benchmark which is you know
just scanning this one giant one
terabyte table of taxi information I did
get into an argument with the author of
that pension rock on hacker news so I
like to give him the chance to respond
to that criticism so his view and he's
not the only one who thinks like this is
that scanning one giant table is the
right thing to do there are some people
who set up their data warehouses in this
way who D normalize everything into a
few giant tables and then when they run
their queries they're not doing any
joints they're really just there they're
just hitting that without one table and
doing the scan speed and so if you are
like that if you are going to set up
your data warehouse like that then that
is actually a good benchmark for that so
there is that kind of community of
people who think that way and that that
benchmark is is right for them the last
thing I want to say is that the
differences in speed between these data
warehouses are small the differences in
costs are medium-sized but like I said
you're probably going to spend more
money on your team and on the tools
around your data warehouse than the data
warehouse itself that shouldn't be
decisive for you what really matters in
my opinion when you're comparing these
data warehouses these are all good
choices but what matters most is
ease-of-use how productive are you going
to be using these data warehouses how
many corner cases are you gonna run into
what kind of surprising behavior are you
going to encounter and in our experience
as of today bigquery and snowflake do
have a leg up over redshift
on that front redshift does require more
babysitting more management it has more
weird corner cases where things worse
will stall where weird stuff will happen
we've seen more troubles with big
customers with busy workloads on red
shift than we have on these other data
warehouses this wasn't true a few years
ago
from where we stand a redshift has
fallen behind a little bit on the
ease-of-use front and then between
between snowflake and bigquery the big
difference is in their support for
transactions and then their support for
the full range of D ml and DD l like
create table weird updates things like
that snowflake has every kind of sequel
statement that you would expect as an
analyst bigquery only has a small
fraction of the you know DDL and DML
statements it depends if you care about
that some people don't care they don't
use those things so does not matter to
them some people care a lot and if
you're looking to load data into your
warehouse we can help you with that we
are as I said a fully managed fully
automated data pipeline that can help
you get all those complex data sources
into your data warehouse we have a booth
downstairs and I'll be doing office
hours at one across the hall and with
that if there's any questions I'd love
to take them questions yeah yeah
I agree with you about caching and not
being realistic to run the same query
identical query twice but if you're
doing interactive business intelligence
then people will run one query and then
they'll run or the tool will run a very
similar query on a very similar set of
data so I would hope a good system would
run faster
you know if I'm querying you know a
similar the same data set with a
slightly different query did you mess
with that tool yeah you're totally right
we tried in order to be fair to that and
because that is what people do they
don't they don't just show up one day
and run a query against the table that's
never been queried before I didn't
mention this but as part of this
benchmark what we did is we ran a select
star against every table before we ran
the benchmark so he ran select star once
against every table - as a hint to the
data warehouse like hey I'm about to
query this table you might want to cache
this thing and then we ran each query
from the benchmark one time other
questions hey I'm sorry sorry I have a
question about Emmys of migration one of
the struggles that we ran into when we
were moving to redshift is the large
number of functions that redshifted in
support and we had to change all of our
transforms and I was wondering how
snowflake and bigquery and it sounds
like a big query is clearly lacking in
that area what about snowflake yeah so
you know these these these these
functions especially if they're not
standard if they're not in the ANSI
standard they're kind of a toy that the
data warehouse vendors use to try to
lock you into their ecosystem so the
first thing I would say is to encourage
everyone to always try to use the
standard function not the non-standard
one because you will someday one a
migrate to a different data warehouse
redshift I think has pretty good
coverage of functions snowflake also has
excellent coverage of sequel functions
big we used to be really bad on this
before they introduced standard sequel
now they're a lot better but then I'm
not a big user of sort of obscure sequel
functions I don't know that I can give
you a good answer to that
my instinct is that in general snowflake
and redshift have better coverage of
sequel but bigquery is catching up
they're making steady progress finally
after five years of not yeah thank you
any more questions we have time for one
or two I was wondering how did you guys
run the queries where they run
concurrently or one after the other one
after the other we did do some tests and
these data warehouses are pretty linear
if you run two queries simultaneously
it'll take about the same amount of time
as if you run them sequentially it's not
perfect but they actually tend to be
pretty linear so it doesn't matter that
much whether you use concurrency or not
Thanks
hi do you do you have any other
benchmarks against like presto or like a
hosted service of presto like a theme
yeah yeah so you know if you go first of
all our benchmark is there was a link
shown some of those slides it's in
github github.com slash 5 trans slash
benchmark presto is in there we actually
did presto as part of it it was way
behind in terms of speed and we
suspected that we had not configured it
correctly that we had just done it wrong
so he didn't publish it we later
determined that we were right it was
badly configured even even when we
configured it better which may still not
be perfect it was still pretty far
behind but now presto has finally
released
well starburst which is the company that
does a lot of the commercial development
of presto has released a stats based
query planner which is going to make a
huge difference to its performance so in
the next iteration of this we will
include presto and it should be it's not
going to be as fast as the commercial
data warehouses but it should be in the
same ballpark
you